all right check check baby
chicken check checkers
check your neck that's what they used to
say a lot
check your neck and people would go like
this
or run a cheese check they say it run a
cheese check on your daddy because
you know my dad was real old when i was
born
and when i was young he was even older
and the older i got the older he got and
i was kind of chasing him
you know age chasing and then he died
but
um a lot of times we do pizza
you know i was on different sporting
teams or my sister was on a little
sporting team you know
a little lesbian group and then they
would
have a pizza party it used to originally
it was if you won
if you won your team got a pizza party
and then that evolved to even if you got
second
and then it became hell if your team
even if you even had a team
you you'd see some kids just we're all
wearing the same jersey never played
anything eating pizza
so it became really just every anybody
could do it
but they used to say run a cheese check
on your daddy because my dad was so old
when he'd have pizza he could you know
the cheese comes off that pie
when you release that slice off that
circle
you really get a lot of that you know
those little little kind of like a
cheese web kind of like a lot of little
cheese little string cheeses
that go from the slice back to that
motherland
that master pie circle and so a lot of
times
you know my dad he didn't know what the
hell was going on
he didn't know you know who was who was
his kid or who was black or who was
white or anything
i mean he didn't know if you were a car
or a person so i remember one time he
put a half a gallon of gas in the back
of my pants
so you just uh you know
daddy would have have him a slice of
that pizza
and he'd have cheese just draped all
over him
and some of the kids would say hey hey
hey hey run a cheese check on your daddy
and you'd have to just kind of you know
check on his face like that
you'd have to do that dang dang da dang
dang
and cheese check your daddy make sure
you don't have any just cheese just
draping off his face
you know like somebody's trying to speed
lunk off his face or something and
so you know you don't you just want to
make sure you know it was kind of that
deal but um
yeah check check chicken chick
that's a popular term they say chicken
chick
because a chicken you know a lot of
people don't think about a chicken
think about a chicken
now what a chicken
you uh seeing a chicken used to be like
like like coming across a mac daniels
bro when you're driving
and you you see that you know you see
the the arches he said oh damn that's a
mcdaniel's right there
that's the same in the old days if you
came across a chicken in the 1600
1700s that's like pulling up on a
restaurant
you know you're riding with your family
you guys are in the uh
you know riding in a horse cart or
whatever you see a chicken they say dad
dad
stop there dad stop at that restaurant
and the restaurant's just over there
it's like
and y'all go over there and slice and
dice
and mom does her thing and that's family
dining that's 1600
family dining man and the chicken dies
but hey
somebody's got to go man and that's
called
that chicken chick happy autumn
we're running right here we're running
up on the heels of winter
if you if you listen you can you can you
can really feel
if you listen with your emotions you can
really
feel us just kind of lapping up onto the
on the heels of winter just nipping at
the heels
just nipping at the heels of that icy
[ __ ]
miss winter and she's doing her thing
but we coming at her baby
let's get into the episode
this is a little matthew causey all
with runs in the family
amen baby
can't save
tell em baby catch me on grinder huh
[Music]
there you go matter maddie
time
there ain't no stopping the sailing sun
i can't wash the sink from the heads and
maybe is in the family
[Music]
amen maddie you can cut me down
but the roots run deep
i ain't gonna die when they bury me
i wonder what i'll do when i die you
know
if i lay there if i'll probably
i'll probably try to sneak over and just
tickle somebody else that's been laying
there
piss somebody off man hey hey
cut out all the [ __ ]
i wonder what what my neighbors would be
like where i get buried that's why
you know people want to get buried by
their family but you got to think about
that
you gotta think about that
you wanna get buried you know
i mean it's nice to be by your mom for
like an hour
but i don't know if you want to be
buried right by her
it's nice to be by your uncle bruh but
if he you know
if he gets into gambling or [ __ ] it
ain't fun
you know it's just it's like who where
do you who do you want to be i almost
wish that they had a um
they had a uh funeral parlor that had a
kind of a 10 disc changer
remember them cd changers them 10 disc
changers
that they had one of those in the ground
and everybody was on kind of a lazy
susan and you just got to kind of
you know just do like a little bit of
speed dating kind of while you're in the
dirt
just somewhere you could cross paths
with with different
with some difference
because yeah for the first hour or two
it'd be cozy being with your folks but
man
about 10 p.m and after they shut down
they saw you know a couple of
episodes at law order svu and they're
turning down the lights you're going to
want to howl a little
you're going to want to get out
you're going to want to throw one of
your bones into the distance
and let some dirty dog go get it
you know that's one thing about skeleton
that's why i think
if skelet if ghosts were made you know
if they had real skeletons
dogs would attack them all the time
so you got to think about that right
there
i mean you know you couldn't send a
skeleton real far without a dog getting
that [ __ ] right by the neck
or by the cossacks or whatever or the
occipital or whatever i don't remember
you know i only got a b in eighth grade
in uh science but
you know shout out to science bro we had
a um
when i was young we had a science
teacher and he used to do uh
deltoids at the gym
and he would do uh deltoids all the time
and he would also at the same time eat
altoids
and so his big thing he would get you to
come over by him and he'd be doing
deltoids and he'd be
and he'd blow a little bit of mint smoke
out of his mouth
and be doing altoids he'd have nine
altoids in his mouth
and i'm not saying that i mean i don't
know what the ph balance is
of somebody's breath if they got nine
altoids in him but
i mean you like a damn christmas chimney
at that point you running a lot of heat
i feel like
and shout out to that man mr cave man
and he went to jail for uh
you know dating underage ladies but
before that he was a good man i'll say
that
and i think he served his time too so
it's you know
and he looked good in a tank top i'll
say that [ __ ]
you know i'm an adult and he's an adult
but hell he looked good in a damn tank
top
what's going on we just had um
the death man in we had frank giles in
here
and i tell you you know it's it's
interesting when you meet a man
that's that close to the dead
and you right there you wit him
you know it's interesting when you when
you meet a man who who
who who's carried a you know that that's
that 15 inch baby
and tucked him into a car seat next to
him and driven him over there to the
death grounds
it's interesting to be that close to
that man and just kind of just hear his
feelings
hell i asked him straight up i said let
me put my hand on your chest
you know let me feel the drum of the of
of of of of death
because when he walks in the room baby
that's it you were to go order for the
lord son you it's time to box you up
and so yeah i guess i start thinking
about that around this time of year
what's it gonna be like
when they close when they roll it up one
more time
you know i tried to fake my death when i
was about 20.
i'll be honest
and my friend paul called a couple
people and said hey you know theo's dead
and
and the [ __ ] the crazy [ __ ] was none of
them even told anybody
so we planted a couple seeds and that
[ __ ] didn't even grow bro
and then we forgot about it you know we
was doing weed we was doing cocaine
daddy you know
i mean i was anyway i don't know if he
was but
you know my favorite type of weed was uh
cocaine you'd see me snorting a bowl of
weed you know
get that little that thanksgiving for
your snout daddy i'm talking about
cocaine
dude i remember i had some i had some
good cocaine one time over there in
tucson arizona
hell i put two grams in my car was out
of gas and that [ __ ] ran for a half an
hour
the headlights wouldn't work but hey you
can't have it all
daddy you can't have it all
and that's god man
what else is going on uh did a show last
night out here
out here in the central east i want to
thank everybody that came out this
beautiful time man
you know and just good to just be in a
room with people and laughing and
feeling good
you know and really just feeling good
and um
um yeah we had a nice time a couple of
young bucks around here got up and did
some comedy
to start the show off you know i was all
i was on the show and
you know they're only the the the the
crowds here at half capacity
so they're you know only allowed about
160 people or something 150 people in
the showroom
so it's kind of nice because it's almost
like you get to practice but
it's still a regular show for everybody
that's there and
um you know it'll just have to make do
for now
you know i'm grateful to have just a
spot to get out there man it really is
uh it really is a good deal
but yeah we had the death man in here we
had him right here
and it's crazy i mean if say fast
forward 40 years from now 80 years from
now when i die
or we're not you know go on
i should have told i should have put my
order in i should have said hey frank i
want this you know i want this and this
i want you know i want the i want the
strawberries and whipped cream
under one under each arm when i'm in
that basket daddy
and i want that wicker casket so you
could still still smell me
so the ladies could still get a off of
my bro loan
you feel me
but i don't know it's tricky how do you
want to go
cremated is too much i don't want to be
you know i worked one day as a damn uh
chef's apprentice over at
um uh
over at road house cafe or whatever that
[ __ ] hole was um
link lock i don't know what it was dude
they were supposed to be selling char
grilled steaks but
the fda showed up and popped them and
got them they were selling um
they were selling illegal uh meat
you know they had to hit a raft in there
they had to hit a pony or something
you know some of the [ __ ] they were
selling was illegal meat
and that's the second time in my life
i've been popped at a joint where
they're selling illegal
you know i was out in tucson arizona and
they had this little chef fella
named little scotty and they popped him
and he wore a big ass hat
too heavy for his neck and you would see
him kind of like this a little bit
and that the hat was so damn heavy it
would close his eyelids
man but you know when you're a chef they
don't give you like a medallion
you know some things that give you a
medallion if you do well
but a chef they give you a big hat looks
kind of like an
like an atomic bomb explosion shape
and he was so damn proud and i think his
daddy thought he was bigger and his
daddy hadn't seen him in a while and his
daddy got him
too heavy of a hat for his little neck
and so he had that big bastard on there
and he could barely keep his eyes open
with that heavy [ __ ] on there
but they uh yeah they got but they were
selling illegal seafood and i remember
the fda showed up
and popped everybody dude you know
some dude asking me if i know about
shrimp [ __ ] i don't know about [ __ ] i'm
a bus
boy okay and they need bread on eight
right now
so don't try to tangle me up all in this
little mermaid [ __ ]
but anyway i'm sorry i don't mean to get
all fired up but um
but yeah we out here that's what i'm
saying and i forgot to tell you a little
bit more about that song on the way in
that was runs in the family
by matthew kazial
talented young felon we'll have the link
there to uh
to his uh to his sound so you can go get
a hold of him
and see what's going on with him and
what's going on with you i'd love to
know i'd love if you guys could hit the
hotline
985-664-9503
and just let me know who's listening to
the to to the show
if you work at a kindergarten say that
say hey this is rhonda
you know i work at a kindergarten you
know
i like skittles or i like to you know
blow a winston every now and then
you know and i like to listen to the
podcast or
you know this is uh timothy
and i'm 40 but i still go by that by by
the name timothy
and um you know i'm a janitorial i do
janitorial by the church
and i listen to the podcast hit the
hotline man let us know who's listening
just so i know what's going on out there
i think it's raining outside
wow i don't know if y'all can hear that
but that's really rain
wow
see i think i would like a cat when i go
i'd like a casket that every now and
then comes up to the surface you could
get hit by little rain you know
um we got a lot of great uh responses
that came in about people talking about
rejection
and you know i i i i'm thankful for the
stories man a lot a lot of just people
sharing rejection
and uh and we'll get into it in just a
minute and i'll talk about rejection uh
but first i gotta let you know about
magic spoon and magic spoon is
i mean it's not what you think it is man
or it might be
you know when i was growing up cereal
was important in our household
we had five major food groups and they
were cereal
cereal see real cereal
[Music]
and that was it man i remember one time
we had 27 boxes of
in our house and you could go in there
and sometimes it was um
you know the older kids would lock you
in the cereal closet
you know and you'd be in there just
frost or flaking your face off and stuff
you have
as much cyril as you could have and you
cry until somebody let you out
but um but it was nice man
and it's nice to go back to those times
in your life and have you sit at night
and have you a bowl
you got the baby put to bed you know
little abigail's put to bed
you know you clean that diaper off and
little abigail's resting you know
or a little lance or whatever his name
is little lancelot
you know you took the chain mail off of
him and and put him to sleep
and now it's your time to have you a
little something to hit that freaking
hit that face
of yours with that magic milk
and magic uh you know sustenance
and who does that for you better than
anybody
is magic spoon you know if you want to
cut down on carbs but still have that
sugar cereal vibe
magic spoon does it zero grams of sugar
11 grams of protein and only three
net grams of carbs in each serving
it come in four flavors cocoa fruity
frosted and blueberry what's blueberry
and you know right there that sounds
like the spice girls if they did a spice
girl reenactment but maybe from you know
um the middle east or from morocco
cocoa fruity frosted and blue bar
and look i'll tell you this it tastes
amazing man it gives you just enough of
that hit
just enough of that childhood dose
of having those magical tastes from back
in the day
but still maintaining your uh
your physicality and your health
it's keto friendly gluten friendly grain
free soy free low carb and gmo free
and right now you can try it go to
magicspoon.com
t-h-e-o to get that variety pack
and try it out today be sure to use
promo code theo at checkout
to get free shipping and magic spoon is
so confident in their product
it's backed with a 100 percent happiness
guarantee
so if you don't like it for any reason
they'll refund your money
no questions asked that's magic spoon
dot com slash theo and use code theo for
free shipping
we thank magic spoon for sponsoring the
podcast
go get a taste of your childhood
man that rain it's really coming in man
i don't know if i keep talking about it
you can't hear you guys aren't even
believing man but this rain man
it sounds like about 30 german shepherds
pissing on a tin
roof man it's this is a hearty batch you
know
this that kind of rain where it's like
you've been in a conference for three
hours and the guy wouldn't stop
doing the power points and you didn't
want to leave because you're already on
you know kind of probation or light
probation with the with the boss
so you waited till the end of the deal
and then you've
chirped out of that out of that crown
plaza uh
showroom and hit that urinal
baby you know i wish they came out with
a product where you could you could
throw it in the urinal and they would
clog it up for about
two minutes you then whenever you
urinated you could see how much you did
because that's one thing i don't like is
um
you do urine but you don't know how much
i mean what's the point of even
you know what's the point of even
pissing if you don't know how much you
did
you know what's the point what's the
point of of making urine if you don't
know how much you just made
so if we can find a way to briefly kind
of clog up a toilet
just long enough for you to kind of have
a little bit of pride in yourself
i think people would feel you know that
pride might carry over back into
the workplace so that's just me
spitballing baby
that's what they call me baby spitball
and vaughn
what else man what else is going on um
oh we got these rejection called man
they're good
they're really really good so i want to
get right into them man and thank you
guys for being a part of this show that
the the the uh number is always
six 985 four nine five zero
three and i want to thank uh raleigh mao
is not here today
and it just just didn't fit kind of with
the schedule we will have him back at
some point
um we got producer sean in today and
he's not in here right now
he's at the hardy's but he um
he is helping us and we are grateful for
that man thank you very much
let's hit a call let's hit the hotline
here we go
[Music]
hi theo this is ashley calling from
indiana and
ashley from indiana baby
in indiana is a real it's a popular
state
one of the probably 50 most popular
states right there gang
and i just heard your segment on being
rejected
and i've never actually been rejected
but i did have to reject someone one
time and it was super embarrassing
i um had a client at my vet clinic
where i was a receptionist for a long
time in a vet clinic you know that's
where they bring animals
oh you got a little pony and he's got
asthma they bring his little ass in
there you know
you know you got a little squirrel bruh
and he got
maybe a leak in his vast deference and
he's eating nuts but he's blowing them
at the same time you know it's just
they do all kind of stuff like that [ __ ]
you can't handle at the house
gang baby onward and um took care of his
dog and gave him his medicine
and told him how to take care of his dog
and told him to have a great day
and he left and he called me back about
10 minutes later and said
that um he knew he was a little bit
older than me but
um i was really kind to him and he had
just gone through a divorce so he wanted
to
take me out on a date but i obviously
well at the time i had a boyfriend and i
said i'm sorry i have a boyfriend but
being the good receptionist that i was
i told him that i could take down his
name and number and call him back
at a later time if things changed well
that's kind of perfect
ashley to uh you know to just be
you know get that response take his
number save it for later
because you also don't know what can
happen you don't know what god's doing
for you
you know you may be getting uh you know
that may that man could be your second
husband what if times get different
you know what if you you know your
current your fiance or whoever that man
the boyfriend falls into a volcano and
now you got you don't know what to do
and you hit up freaking dog daddy and
he's got a little bit of money
next thing you know you know you over at
his house early one morning
making a couple of quick cakes for him
in the pooch it's
you know it's uh you just don't know you
gotta save numbers
you gotta save numbers you gotta you
gotta hedge your bets
you know my daddy used to he's when the
church plate would come around my daddy
would throw a business card in it
you know he's supposed to put money in
there and he put that business card in
and uh i think he thought they were like
drawing for like a free lunch or
something but he would throw that
business card in there
and he didn't even he he didn't even
have any business his business was
nothing
his business was trying not to uh you
know
sleep on the sofa at night that was his
his business was just trying not to make
my mom mad
so he but he would throw it in there
dude i don't even think it had any phone
number i think he just had his name on
it and said business card on it
and he'd throw that bastard in there
you know i think he's just hedging his
bets you notice in case down the line
you know he's thinking maybe the lord
needs somebody and
he hits you know he's got that card
everybody else has just been tithing
cash but pops throws in that little
that little connection piece so
let's hear the rest of the call man i'm
sorry i interrupted young lady
i don't know why i don't know it was
like i was trying to get him in for a
rabies shot the next week i don't know
what was going through my head it was
super embarrassing
and i took down his name and number and
held onto that piece of paper
like i was gonna call him back at some
point um
so i really hope that guy moved on
and i think you will too so good luck
out there
well thank you yeah and this is you know
i got rejected by a woman at the crepery
and i still sat there point blank and
ate a crepe right in front of her
so you may see me on a future episode of
mind hunter
but um but i'll say this ashley one of
the reasons
and i'll get into the psyche of a male
one of the reasons this man probably did
this because you took care of his dog
and and in fact a dog is is an appendage
of a man's
you know private baby that weiner
and and
some men got that little yapper some men
got that growler
some men got that snuggler wiener
some men got that winter wiener where
their wieners always kind of hibernate
but if you treat a man's puppy well or
treat his dog well then he
in his mind that's a reflection
oh this is how she's going to treat the
rest of my body
you know a dog is really it's an
extension of a man and it's not exactly
an extension of his p of his privates of
his penis
but it's it it kind of has that same if
you had an extra penis that could catch
a frisbee
that's what your dog is
you gotta think into the male psyche
and um so if he sees you treating that
thing he sees you you know
petting the dog and giving it a little
you know maybe a little treat maybe a
chicken liver
he's going to say oh ah you know if
she'll take care of that she might take
care of the rest of me
because uh you know i remember being
really young you'll try to
i remember your penis become so alive at
a certain point in your life
i mean when you're 13 or 12 or 14
your penis is like a i mean it just
it's just so damn insane
it's like having a um
it's like having a chatty friend
you know you're trying to be cool and be
calm and then
i want some tears you know your penis
just
activating you gotta do so you gotta you
gotta handle them or mangle them
you know i remember when i was young
trying to even feed my penis like a
little uh
captain crunch i remember i get a little
pocket knife and cut the cap and crunch
kernels in the halves and try to
you know you know feed one of your damn
wiener i guess or just you know being
young man and just
anyway i think that's why the man hit on
you because you know he
you came at the dog
but i think it's beautiful and i think
it's a compliment
and he probably just was looking for
somebody to show him a little bit of
care
and you were the first one around him
you know
it's crazy how we all could use some
care man
we all used somebody to pat us on the
neck or to
you know throw a frisbee or give us a
little chicken liver
man if y'all can hear that rain it is
cool though i almost wish i was out in
it
and the police as well you hear them the
police are around here
but yeah i went i went kayaking on the
out on the harpeth
about a two-hour run out there
you know a couple people out there
drinking mountain dew code reds you know
and it was nice man this one nice thing
out here
in tennessee was really a perfect day
because the
the weather was it was fall but it was
hot
so it's 80 degrees but it's you know
october whatever
20th or something
so though all the foliage had shifted
you know because mother nature likes to
use different crayons man she don't
you know she goes she goes heavy on the
green for a while but once she starts to
realize there's other colors in the box
that [ __ ] gets extravagant baby
and one thing in tennessee you can see
that foliage man
so you could really you just you know
we're just yakking through these creeks
and you just see the
just all these trees and leaves and
just the endless soundtrack of god man
nature
it's just a playlist that
this is a playlist that's
it's never ending man as far as we know
let's take another call 985-664-9503
what's up theo this is chris from
connecticut what's up christopher
chris and chris is short for christopher
a lot of times
or christmas or christening
or what else
and that's it let's hear more i'm
calling about uh getting turned down
which
made me think of a story from college i
had went to a bar with
a couple my friends it was after a uh
intramural softball game
oh yeah intramural softball i feel you
baby
intramural softball dude
there was always some psycho on every
team he had like nine headbands
he's putting on i black he's doing coke
he's like
then he hits a double and tears his acl
his name's always hank let's hear more
brother let's go christopher
so uh you know how that is but uh
basically i
i'm dancing by myself which is another
great part of the story i forgot
but i'm dancing by myself and some girls
dancing with some guy
and i look over and she kind of gives me
the swoop to pull her in so i kind of
swoop over i'm thinking smoothly and
start grinding up on this girl
and uh it she she's digging it you know
she's down she
she's grinding up on me and we're
dancing and i just went in for the kiss
thinking like you know
next step is trying to make out with her
and she stops me immediately and goes
whoa whoa whoa you are too
sweaty and truth be told about you
everybody else i probably was too sweaty
after that softball game but uh
yeah that's my turn down story basically
she wasn't having it so
hope that works for the podcast love you
man gang gang
buzz buzz as always and uh keep [ __ ]
going man we love you love everything
you got
love you too man thank you bro i love
you too man and thanks for that for that
for that statement
and i'll tell you this man uh you know
sweat is really sweat is that body river
it's that baby glaze man
i mean sweat is it's a part of
you know a mother sweats when she bring
her child into the world
you know you don't want to see you don't
want to you know be born and your
mother's dry as hell
like damn who's this am f
you know who's this dang uh arachnid
you know you want to be you want you
want that drippy mom after it
you know you don't want you i mean i
want to be born i want my mother in a
damn
tank top you feel me i want her looking
like she just had
you know had been doing two a days i
don't want one of these dry ass mothers
having a child
and that's sweat man
sweat is just advertising that you've
been trying
that's all it is man you know it takes
eight minutes to get sweat
sweat's not a free gift
you know anybody could just do some
[ __ ] but somebody's got to do some
[ __ ] at a decent heart rate for
eight minutes
to be sweating and way to go dancing by
yourself man that says
dancing by yourself the ultimate sign of
confidence
if you look at different television
shows or programs or
even drawings some drawings
you'll see somebody dancing by
themselves
and there's there's nothing it's a sign
of confidence man if a guy is dancing by
themselves
at first a lot of other guys will like
man look at this fool
but nine out of 10 times that guy ends
up dancing with a woman
a some woman meanders over to that guy
there's something magical about it
there's something magical about that
just that confidance baby that french
confidence man
there's something just warm about it
there's something inviting
so more power to you man it sounds like
you're on a great track you're doing
you know you're dancing by yourself
you're doing your own thing
you're doing softball do co-ed softball
that way you kind of killing two birds
with one stone
hit you know hit it inside the park
homer because that's all people hidden
in softball and then uh
and then you know dance when you get to
home plate
you know and you already have women
there at the place you don't have to go
to the pub
dude i remember one time we used to play
softball and they put this dude la
davious man and he was
um he was an urban youngster
if i'm real honest with you might have
been a little bit sh
he might have had a little hit of
shanghai in him or something but he uh
i don't know he had that kind of he
looked a little you know sleepish if you
will he had that gas leak kind of vibe
but
um and he was in a wheelchair bro he was
wced up and they put him out in left
field by me
so i had to be out there with him
so every now and then you know the ball
if he got hit high enough i'd try to
push him over there to get under it man
and we were man we were horrible
we were horrible
i'll tell you what's not horrible though
is fatter
fire t brand one unexpected side effect
of this year is uh
fashion we don't even know what is
fashionable anymore
it's like sweatpants were forced into
fashion because
everybody's at home you know
uh zoom suddenly became fashion
everything
it has changed fashion has changed
there's no like going out attire
it's all changed so how are we supposed
to know what to shop for
right now well do what i do don't buy
for now
buy for forever for timeless pieces that
will last
a lifetime of where check out farady
faraday makes high quality comfortable
clothing for life
and that's what you need a lot of people
are shopping like i got this in two
weeks i got this in a month
i got everything forever
that's what i need clothes for every
piece is made to laugh
last a lifetime guaranteed
you know faraday is committed to
community and the environment in all
they do
they donate to the surf rider foundation
and one percent for the planet
the company is family run by the faraday
family
and they are hands-on ensuring value in
everything they do
if you haven't checked out faraday
you'll want to they have uh
you know they just have a kind of it's
like
patterns and and and not
patterns things that are yeah i guess
timeless is the really per
the perfect word i mean you could be on
a boat you could be reading a book you
could be taking a walk with your loved
one
you know you could be picking up a kiddo
or or sitting at a ball field i mean
they just have this kind of
yeah this timeless vibe um
it's practical it's cute it's
comfortable it's
it's different man you know buying
forever is the smartest way to shop
you know it's too it's it's over you
just buy for this or buy for that man
there is no this or that really right
now everything is the same
every moment is the same and faraday is
meeting you there
right now you get up to 25 percent off
your next fire t purchase
when you go to com faritybrand.com
theo that's f a h e r
t y fairty brand dot com
slash theo for twenty five percent off
faritybrand.com theo
go see what they have um it's
comfortable it's
it's quality it's it's forever i gotta
tell you about uh
this deal right here is athletic greens
and i ordered them for my dang mother
and i'll tell you this she won't leave
me alone now she used to leave me alone
and now she won't
and i got to attribute that gumption and
that
vitality to athletic greens you know the
perfect diet doesn't exist
and i'll tell you why because your day
changes
you can say i'm gonna do this forever
i'm gonna do this for six weeks
but the day changes your money is
different your tuesday or wednesdays
it's all it's like oh man today i got up
later then i got up earlier and then
this and then work and then you know
a wife lawsuit everything but now that
that can all be different because with
athletic greens it's that one cup shop
you get up you drop that powder
and it's next level greenery i mean it's
like somebody just drug you through mr
mcgregor's garden with your mouth open
man it's like somebody just beat you in
the face with the damn produce section
perfect greens handles it all if you're
looking for one product that has as much
high quality nutrients
in it as possible then you want to
consider athletic greens
as many as 75 vitamins and minerals
multi minerals
green complex probiotics prebiotics for
gut health
and immunity formula digestive enzymes
and
adaptogens the multivitamin that goes
the
extra mile it encompasses all the other
nutrient categories you get it all
immune system support
gut health support and right now
athletic greens is giving
my audience a special offer on top of
their all-in-one formula
which is a free liquid vitamin d
supplement
with your first purchase for additional
immune support
you know we're heading into winter and
you want to have some vitamin d it's
crucial
it is crucial if you can't get the sun
then you want to get it some
how and this is how so if you're looking
to upgrade
your multivitamin or take one
nutritional formula that's going to help
cover your daily nutritional basis
then you want to consider athletic
greens athletic greens makes as
getting as much high quality nutrition
as possible incredibly
easy and right now you can go to
athleticgreens.com
theo you'll receive up to a year's
supply of liquid vitamin d
for free with your first purchase look
it's a great christmas gift for someone
someone who's maybe going to try a new
diet this will i tell you this
you put it in the glass you mix it in
you take it ka-boom
ka-boom i mean it's like operation
desert storm baby this thing makes you
feel fire-ocious
go to athleticgreens.com t-h-e-o
and support the podcast all right let's
take another call
here
gang baby boy what's happening with you
what up son not much
hey a long time first time here
yeah i'm calling about the rejection and
one time my
first day in my brand new apartment i
get in the elevator
there's this just oh just
gorgeous for that moment way out of my
league comes and i got me and my dog
right
oh yeah you got that little hit man with
you baby
and uh she's actually excited to see the
dog she gets been all
happy starts petting my dog oh yeah and
this goes back to it
once you touch that dog and the man
imagination
goes from that wiener dog to just that
wiener you feel me
i froze up man i locked up the only
thing i'd come up with was
oh you like dolma
and she looked at me like i was probably
the dumbest thing on planet earth that
gave me a smile probably because she
felt bad at that
but then we had to take the elevator ten
stories
up in this awkward embarrassed
i didn't know what to say i was all red
i was sweaty man
that's never been the same since gang
gang
gang brother you never will be the same
man
that rejection it it sticks in you man
like a
like a magnet with talons man it just it
gets
into you it each ass
baby at each ass with buck teeth
oh man in the elevator i mean first of
all
there's so many things going on in that
story first of all
elevators if we if we focus
if we just build an elevator that went
all the way to heaven
we wouldn't have we would you know we
wouldn't have a lot of the problems we
have
but instead we're building two store
three four three stories
dude sometimes you see a building with
two stories as an elevator
[ __ ] just throw your friend up there
dog [ __ ]
jump we got wasting all of this money
and also if we we if we had if we had an
elevator that went all the way up to
heaven
you know we do two stories three stories
you know you go to a dentist you go to
some tax evasion place
you go to chiropractor bruh dude look if
a chiropractor ain't on the first
floor that place is a scam bro okay
fact you know i don't
i don't want to go to the bent house
daddy i want to go to the penthouse man
i'm going to go all the way to the top
we should make an elevator that goes to
heaven man
think about it that way when you're
ready to go you're ready to go
it's not a bad idea man but dude yeah
it's so tough when you get with the girl
you start and you
you have a chance and you're like you
like dogs
and then you just
there's nothing you can do so when your
voice gets locked up
and you have to ride floor after floor
just thinking what do i say now
and anything would have anything would
have been okay
you could have said anything man you
could have said anything
you're just looking at your dog you keep
petting your dog like a pervert
oh that's heartbreaking man and i've
been there and we've all been there
i mean if you're listening to this
podcast you've definitely been rejected
by women and
and we've all been there man we've all
been there
oh that's a frustration
just each floor i'm a i'm a loser i'm a
loser i'm a loser i'm a loser
oh it's hectic man but at least you were
in the elevator at least you had a
chance
you know i don't want to realize
sometimes but i realize
men get with who they're brave enough to
talk to
that's who you end up with a man's wife
is whoever
they were brave enough to talk to
unless the woman picks the man sometimes
that happens these days
i'm drinking this mountain water called
liquid death
and it's supposed to be one of the most
fine waters they have
from australia
or somewhere damn it's good too man
god it tastes wet bro damn
it tastes like a million children just
kind of gleaking into your mouth you
know
and not children like children children
just like hypothetical
adult you know
non ageless children i'm not talking
nothing wild bro so get off my
get off of me on that but yeah man hey
at least you had a dog bro
at least you and your dog are sitting
there and your dog's like man
i did my part i wing manned as good as i
could she petted me
all you had to do was say something
i think you owe your dog an apology
though brother but i feel you man thanks
for sharing
we got another call that came in here
985-664-9503
what up deal this is greg so you
mentioned uh
rejection well check what's up greg
and that's short usually for gregory or
gregarious is something different that's
more of an urban name but gregory for a
white
let's go check this out i was in somalia
like the worst place you could ever be
in the world
yeah i don't know dude i've been to a
wawa in philadelphia
after about 1 40 a.m
dude and i saw a guy shoot a 22-caliber
gun right through a um
right through a ham and egg um
sandwich and that [ __ ] [ __ ] blew out
the glass and that [ __ ] was pretty
pretty dicey but uh not challenging you
just uh
just kind of trying to relate i guess
onward getting shot at
and i get back to uh our our base
and i have a letter from my fiance
holding on my back yep so i can hear all
your story i'm sorry for interrupting
you
and thanks for your service man well
check this out i was in
somalia like the worst place you could
ever be in the world
getting shot at and i get back to uh our
our base and i have a letter from my
fiance
saying she just moved in with some dude
rude jack did i had to go out in the
desert
look into the sun until my tears dried
up
anyways hey i love your show king gang
gang bro dang
man that's hectic man
that's hectic man
oh
you know i bet i'm going out on a limb
here
but i bet i bet it was real painful at
the time man
but i bet after a certain point or in
hindsight years later i bet you're able
to look back and be like man i'm glad
that i was
far away because then you're not there
to have to deal with the
breakup you're not right there to have
to drive past each other and see each
other at the
at the twice daily or at the you know
tom thumb or whatever
you know it's um
i think there's probably some blessing
in that
now also being out there in the desert
is sheer hell man
i remember i went to kuwait one time to
do some military shows and
i was on cigarettes and i was doing
cigarettes broad puff out bruh
i was jerking off and puffing out you
know i was basically just doing my best
and um
and i remember it was too hot to even
smoke
it was too hot to even smoke a cigarette
the air outside was hotter than a
cigarette
was so if you inhaled a cigarette it was
almost
it was a colder it felt like than the
regular air
so it was just worthless you know it was
pointless it just you could just inhale
the regular air and it felt like a
cigarette
so hot
and i remember some girl went on their
morning run or something and she stopped
by my little cabin or whatever
and tried to make love to me and i
couldn't get an erection
so i mean she was petting my dog man
with
she was petting my dang dog and that
thing
just wasn't waking up i think it might
have been down it was just
old yellow bro my my my wiener was dead
man
what else man uh oh i'll tell you that
one thing that about about uh
being in an elevator that gets my
girdle i mean it just boils my damn
beef uh boils my beef
is when somebody gets in with a little
child
and they're like okay okay tanner press
the button
and tanner's standing there he's got all
10 fingers up his nose
you know he's just straight bug hunting
he don't give a damn
and they're like all right tanner
preston button
and tanner's like
then he beats his damn little booger
hunters up against the
alt like you know up against all the
buttons
and it reminds me actually i got to tell
you this one this one story uh
i'm in an elevator i'm going back to
elevators and i'm in the elevator i get
in and this couple gets in at the same
time
and they have a little child man and
this child probably been alive maybe i'm
guessing
probably 170 days you know he still
smelled a little gamey
still a little gamey in the air
and uh you know like if an animal came
up i bet he would pick that little baby
up by the back of the neck you know what
i'm saying he's still a little
fresh out that mom body
so we're in there we get in and
i i felt like the mom had maybe been
drinking and she said to the husband she
said oh honey maybe dunstan will want to
press the button
and first of all you can't name a baby
dunstan
you can't name a baby dunstan man i
think dunstan is a as a baseball bat
you can't name a baby dunstan
think about a baby named dunstan dude
yeah you can't so
i'm looking i'm like dunstan and i'm
looking at the baby and i'm thinking
well sure
surely she doesn't mean the baby the
baby is five months old
that baby couldn't dunstan will have he
he you know he can't
move his arms he don't he's like a
scarecrow with no scare in him
he can't do nothing you know
um i mean a snake could eat him
you know he has no dumpster don't have
any capabilities
so she's like done honey honey maybe
dustin would like to push the buttons
and i'm standing there like we gotta get
going
you know we've been about 18 seconds
that's a long time
to start it for an elevator to start in
modern day
so then the husband he has he has his
look on his face like what like i don't
know
but then you can tell who wears the
pants and the family the lady
and i don't know if she like wanted to
show off for me or what she's thinking
but
next thing you know the guy like puts
you know dunstan by the
buttons and he don't do nothing i knew
he wasn't gonna do nothing
and i'm thinking man i wish i had a law
degree somebody needs to be here
on behalf of dustin
somebody could have done some best
interests man
and then they take dunstan man and the
dad like puts him by the thing and he's
not pressing him
because he can't press him because he
can't do
anything the only thing he's pressing or
even thinking about pressing is just
pressing a tit into his face you know
he's that milk hound baby
he's that [ __ ] leche weasel daddy
so now he like takes the baby
and like pushes the baby against the
buttons
like the side of the bait like the
shoulder and the ear and the
in in the head he like pushes like three
buttons
with little dunstan is pushing him up
against the buttons man
and i pushed my own man he's like what
floor you want to go to i was like
i'll give dunstan's already done enough
man we're going to four [ __ ] floors
that none of us are on
i'll go where i need to go i'll handle
my own [ __ ] all right let's take another
call here
yo theo what's up it's your boy matt
from uh [ __ ] new york and
what's up matt and good to hear from
from you my man and thank you for
calling and being a part of the show in
new york
one of the premier states one of the
first states they ever had in new york
onward no i heard you got rejected
it sucks man i've been there thank you
brother
yep we uh we all have and it's good to
hear that others have more
so i had a funny rejection story so i
was working at planet fitness at the gym
and uh
i don't know if we're gonna call planet
fitness a gym man but i'll go on with
you
i'll go on with you here this cute uh
asian girl would come in there
and i kind of had a thing for it so i'd
flirt with her you know whatever
and oh yeah baby that pinoy daddy onward
and uh i was nervous to ask her out
though she seemed really shy
i couldn't tell if she was into me or
not and that's the asian dilemma right
there when it comes to white males and
uh
and asian women you have no idea
you have no idea you could be getting
married to an asian woman and you have
no idea if she
likes you or not there is no
i mean if i were asian i would just play
poker
no one has any idea
what is going on you could be
a brain surgeon you could work at a
hardee's
i there's no gives onward
and then like some of my co-workers
hyped me up they're like yo man go for
it go for it
so i thought oh i'm gonna i'm gonna do
it big i'm gonna buy her a flower
i got her a rose and i hid the rose like
behind the desk and i waited for her to
leave
oh man so much romance
onward and this is the most embarrassing
thing because
she walked out into the parking lot and
i followed her
out like now saying it out loud it
sounds so creepy
but at the time i thought it would be
like romantic
and i said hey excuse me and then she
turned around and i
gave her the flower and i was like you
know maybe we should we should uh
go go out sometime you know give me a
chance blah blah blah
and she's like uh she was so
she felt so awkward i could tell and
like at this point i knew i
i [ __ ] up and she's just like oh i'm
busy with school
and stuff whatever and then like it was
horrible because then she would come
in to work out and i'd have to see her
again and then every time i was like
trying to hide and [ __ ]
so yeah we've all been there man so
don't feel bad
but anyway getting gay
gang brother dang what a
story man oh i can feel it you hid that
flower the whole time
one of your co-workers noticed they're
all like chatting behind your back like
damn he's about to [ __ ]
take an l you know
and you're all fight you hyped up and
and once your mind goes over that cliff
of i'm gonna take a flower to a girl you
it's bro it ain't the 1800s i feel you
i love the romantic side it's just not
as appreciated
these days people think you're a stalker
people think you're a stalker with a
you know who also has a you know green
thumb
but man i commend it bro you hiding that
[ __ ]
you know you got a little bit of foliage
tucked off behind the xerox
you sneak over tada
she's shocked and then she gave you the
most age i have to go to school more
i have to go to school more
come on at least come up with some
others i'm on you know do something else
i'm on swim team i have to
swim all the time anything other than
that
i have to go to school but honestly bro
in some asian traditions man that's the
thing
it's school or die bro there's not a lot
of middle ground you know you and a lot
of asians they get a b
they go missing and that's documented
man
and then going back to the gym man i
respect the hustle
i don't know if it's anytime fitness or
planet fitness one of
them dude it's like seven times like
seven dollars a month you go in there
there's a cocaine anonymous meeting
going on
in one corner of it little boos he's in
another corner shooting a rap video
you know some guys some guys using one
of the overhead pull down bars to pry
off an
ankle bracelet someone left a baby in a
box
at the bottom of the stair master uh
there's a produce section for some
reason
there's people practicing for
supermarket sweep in there
uh it's just there's some guy who has an
aquarium
it's like what enough it just none of it
makes any sense a lot of people are just
going there to
to bathe some guy's storing stuff in
there
like you going some guys like has 40
locks on all the lockers in there and
he's just storing all of his [ __ ]
instead of getting like a regular
storage
um and i don't know if that's anytime
fitness or planet fitness but one of
them man
one of them will leave you will leave
you uh wanting more sometimes
but you get that grind baby
you get that grind and that's what's
important man and that's what's
important about your story man you got
that grind dog
dude i remember
when i was in let me think sixth
seventh grade there was this rich girl
and i don't know she might not have been
rich but she was rich to me man
she had two parents
she had a like a cat that was doing well
you know she was they were you know she
was doing good
and i remember we went to their
basketball game and i got me a flower
bro got me a rose in advance and i got
it was nice dude it was like two dollars
and 20 cents and they wrapped it up and
that was an extra dollar
and i went all in i had to get a ride
all the way out to the other school
and i went with one of my oh i actually
rode out with one of my buddies because
he was dating another girl
and um and he was dating another girl
and so
we went to the basketball game and
dude she was on the cheerleading team
and at one point they sat down because
they you know they dance team or
something
and i walked over there dog and my face
was turning red as could be
and i got down on one knee bro down on
one hoof man like a marriage i didn't
know what to do
i didn't know how to do it i got down on
one knee bruh
like a marriage and i gave this chick a
dang
rose man and the ball came bouncing over
like that you know
i wasn't even playing ball like you know
like what a loser i think some kid
called me
the n word again it was just bad i think
even the referee called me the n-word
but that was love man i gave it a shot
you know there's something valuable in
that
you know you you're unforgettable
you know you're dancing bro
everybody else is standing around and
doing this and sliding into the dms man
and you're sliding into that
demilitarized zone baby
you're sliding right into into shanghai
man
you know you're showing up in real life
sliding into the demon but that rose
baby
that shakespeare move
and there's some value in that does you
know you're dancing man
everybody else is kind of doing the walk
but you're
you're dancing and when you dance by
yourself dog that never goes away
however you do that in your life it
comes out in all different types and
facets man
so that's what we do here man
we get rejected bruh but we show up
and i'm happy to be showing up for
myself today man it's not always easy
but
you know you guys are always there for
me and support and uh
and i appreciate that and and i try to
do the same as much as i can for you
um so gang man love you guys man uh
yeah what else do we have going on we
got some good episodes coming up joe coy
will be on um
what else we're trying to have uh we've
got a couple of neat guests on i don't
want to say them yet because we're
we're close to having them but you know
we're really hopeful
and what else man
i just hope you're doing okay wherever
you are today
you know i hope you know that uh
you know that you're loved man there's
people thinking about you whoever you
are
even if maybe you feel like there isn't
um sometimes it's not that people don't
love us is that we can't feel it
you know and i hope you find a way to
get out there this week and drop that
rose or hit somebody with that foliage
dog
you know what i'm saying i'm a damn
dandelion
that's some lil hoe bruh be real with it
so we'll go out the way that we came in
man
cause that's life baby
how we gonna go out how we gonna come in
we gonna dance while we here
we going to show that foliage while
we're here
damn your co-workers brother invest they
let you
ride out into the distance dog damn
but that's fine man they ain't us dog
they they back there doing they probably
loaned some man
you're going to find somebody going to
find your lady gwenevere dog
amen 100 fool 100
fool we'll go out the way we came in man
with
matthew kazial and runs in the family i
would tell you if any new shows have
coming up but i don't have any um
you know we're still dealing with the
disease and
and corvid lurks man or does it who
knows we don't know everything
the elections coming up
you know i've already made my choice i
choose people man i choose people over
politics man i just
i've been thinking a lot about it and
i'm not i'm just not letting these
forces divide me from people
i mean we already losing connection here
and there and now
now they got people on you know putting
us on different sides playing this big
dirty game a red rover
you know i will vote i will vote
um and i encourage you to vote for
whoever you want to
whoever you want to um
but in my heart i think i need to make
another choice and that's
and that's for people man
you know but also i don't know what i'm
talking about so
but i love you man i'll see you with
that at that anytime fitness baby
anytime fitness and florist gang
this is matthew kazial with runs in
the family
be good to yourself
[Music]
in the mud
[Music]
come on man
runs in the family
baby
section
[Music]
come
maybe
baby
[Music]
wow unless matthew causey all runs in
the family i want to just take a second
to thank everybody too that supports the
patreon man we don't
you know we don't push a big patreon and
that's fine and we don't want to uh
but we're just doing some good stuff
over there and for the people that do
i feel like i don't say thank you enough
uh so thank you very much
um and we love you
yeah now i'm just floating on the breeze
and i feel like these leaves i must be
cornerstone
oh but when i reach that ground i'll
share this piece of mind i found i can
feel it
[Music]
a little time
for me to set that parking brake and let
myself
on my heart shine
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Music]
and now i've been moving way too fast on
the runaway train with a heavy load of
my
hands
and these rails that i've been riding on
they want something that they're damn
they're gone
[Music]